[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday June
6th you may be wondering why I'm coming
to you from a bathroom in a lot Quinta
Inn in Indianapolis Indiana I can't
really account for the fact that I'm
going to like into it I mean I guess we
were trying to save money or something
but it sure is nice in here I mean the
bathroom because I have to record my
video very early in the morning and I
don't want to wake the Yeti up and yetis
can get a little cranky when you wake
them up early today is the day that we
are hopefully closing on our house and
that will make us like officially
homeowners and like literally I'm gonna
have to mow the lawn tonight can you
move on at night are there regulations
about that that's just one of the many
things I don't know about being a
homeowner Hank anyway Hank we're going
to spend pretty much all day and all
night on this whole like a house
purchasing thing and you may also be
wondering why I'm sitting here in my
boxer shorts well that's a very
reasonable question by the way I am in
my boxer shorts but I'm not going to
prove it you're just going to have to
take my word for it because I don't roll
that way sure would it be helpful to our
YouTube views if maybe I were to show a
little more skin probably probably but
you know I think there are other ways to
get to the top Hank like for instance
making sure that a picture of Lindsay
Lohan in a bikini is your still shot
Hank the reason that I'm in my boxer
shorts is because my pants are full of
people Hank the Brotherhood 2.04 in my
pants has only been in existence for
about eight hours and there already been
200 posts the forum also has nearly 100
registered viewers in its first eight
hours of existence Hank I'm so excited
that there are so many people in my
pants talking about the things there at
the core of what it really means to be
human like whether or not george w bush
is adequately evil to be put into the
evil baby orphanage peg I can't tell you
how happy I am to finally be having
lively discussions about the ego baby
orphanage in my pants and I really
appreciated your John McCain retraction
in my pants although you're still under
estimating Obama buk buk buk buk buk buk
but also I can't believe you're going to
be a TV star I mean it sounds like this
show is going to do for the weather
what I love the 80s dude for vh1 I mean
Hank you're going to be huge you're
going to be the Michael Ian Black of the
Weather Channel who else are they going
to get to be like the fresh funny face
of The Weather Channel anyway Hank it's
time for me to go to the bank now and
take all of the money I've ever earned
out of the bank and put it into a house
not that I'm worried not worried it's
going to be okay
I'm scared I hope everyone has a great
day in my pants by the way I am NOT
going to get tired of that joke Hank
I'll see you tomorrow